[Musica]
la madonna ma che figo sì sì 6 klose
reato meisel terra gara ben parata da un
mezzo bella tutti ragazzi vogliamo solo
io sono parigi oggi s'è andati su xiii
secolo perché hanno fatto la versione
del gioco reato mai se vuol dire che
l'hanno rimasterizzato e quindi niente
facciamolo vi spiego in breve vico de
sisti se c'è un apocalisse nucleare
quindi bombardato tutto una famiglia
sopravvive in un bunker sotterraneo e
devi riuscire a sopravvivere con le
scorte di cibo che ogni giorno succede
qualcosa di strano questo esisti se
mettiamo difficoltà mettiamo ho fatto
mai perché tanto non sono mai riuscito
canale realtà simona volte l'ho finito
però è già difficile così quindi
lasciamo perdere allora qualche bello è
vero che l'hanno rifatto rimasterizzato
e lei devo raccogliere tutti gli oggetti
sono in casa nel mentre ne va ma non
hanno già dove deve scattare l'allarme
prima generi non faccio mai l'inizio
ragazzi io vado direttamente già nel
rifugio che ho già preso le robe perché
sono un casino questa roba ma hanno
aggiunto anche delle cose che non
c'erano prima
ma dai che sta scoraggiando me non ci
possono domani mio marito la figlia e la
teniamo una mappa la mappa ramato alla
mappa la figlia ma poi la figlia la
mamma la figlia la mamma la figlia alla
figlia a dio mio che problemi sto gioco
ogni volta l'ansia va bene let's be game
mamma mia che abbia una sega proviamo
questo ma scusate ma a pescare erano
spostati b punti dove hanno messo le
cose
perché l'hanno favori cambiato
fighissimo guarda ma che roba ma
bellissimo quando ci si trova insieme
agli spazi angusti bellissimo giunto il
sacco di roba ragazzi i primi giorni
sono così ci teneva in scioltezza
presidente passa meglio hanno capito una
roba prima se moriva il papa mi pare che
il gioco orfini va cioè vuole papa se
sei morto adesso che ho scelto la mamma
di amori e la mamma
finché siamo assicura è meglio restare
con tenda non è più ha sedato non hanno
più 7 però mangiare io ragazzi ma allora
partì scherzo poi siamo abbastanza
ottimisti ma non so parlare siamo
abbastanza ottimisti per la spedizione
vabbè allora io manderei fuori la figlia
mary jane
perché non so dare tutto sempre da fini
io gliela do la valigia in modo da
riempirla cioè non per portarsi fuori le
cose c'è proprio per portarli dentro
perché la valigia ci permette di
prendere un sacco di roba l'acqua e cose
va emergendo mangiarti la valigia detto
questo io non sopravvivere mai non
mangiando per così tanto tempo il rosso
come fanno prove e davvero strano che lo
si ha la sensazione che se osservati il
nostro rifugio è piccolo ma questo
pensiero ci tormenta da tempo c'è
qualcosa di vivo qui oltre a noi abbiamo
contratto tutti gli armadi non abbia
trovato nessuno e se fosse un roditore
beh se così fosse vogliamo dimostrare
che siamo noi la per noi una mosca ma
vedi pato l'audio della maschera watts
valascia l'acqua ma appena prima di
uscire due occhi animaleschi si sono
accesi nell'oscurità abbiamo sentito
rinviare in modo terrificante
abbiamo pochi atti per decidere che cosa
fare niente perché tanto cosa vuoi fare
lo spruzzino non mimo ritene per il
tizio né per la quale per la fame grazie
perfetto un po morti non stiamo andando
male
secondo me c'è rispetto al solito
facciamo schifo ma non così tanto
l'acqua vedove sono ancora qui a tavola
tutta per fortuna abbiamo portato a
radio possiamo sfruttare un po di radio
maria che na figata in suo periodo no
stomaco di dead brontola ma se vi ha
dato da mangiare adesso i roditori pu
tanti stanno ascoltando le nostre
provviste cavoli vostri non so niente
per difendermi 6 mary jane conta più a
posto
ciao mary jane non c'è tre gambe vero no
però ti col al naso fame stanchezza
malattia va bene quella bestia di romito
rammento ci ha sconfitti ci ha rubato
ancora leggeva o finiremo le zuppe coi
roditori
niente ci ha mai resi felici così tanto
quanto vedere mary jane tornare nel
rifugio sana e salva
ci ha portati che cosa ci ha portato due
di acqua e una maschera ed ai e lasciava
bene dai voti danno non male mary jane
normale doveva mangiare qualcosa e molto
stanca e si è preso qualcosa di brutto
tutto ciò abbiamo né cibo a tutti i
ragazzi non ho più cibo devo darlo a
tutti per forza c'è un sacco di acqua ma
zero cibo ed ti devo mandare fuori
perché se non ti mando fuori qua è un
casino
mamma mia meno male che avevo la valigia
per portare landia ad acqua siamo a
posto e roditori c'è un [ __ ] lele le
scatole non avevo modo per per
affrontarli maledizione fuori e porti la
valigia porta le cose ti prego giorno 12
guarda quante poche provviste abbiamo
0,25 di bindi fame timi doveva
dell'andare della mamma mia meijin
dovrebbe mangiare qualcosa non è
migliorata sente riposata sviene in
continuazione dobbiamo dove cosa bere a
mary jane vere e basta
timmy bere e basta dolores vere e basta
tutti bene ma stava bene
bevete però non posso darmi nient'altro
raga non ho più niente emergenze ferita
non ha detto nulla e non l'abbiamo
notato fino ad ora non è stato un
problema ma adesso la ferita infetta
lista male bisogna aiutarla
taglia nel braccio a questa braccio non
ce l'ho ancora è successo lo lascia non
c'è più religione ha frainteso quando ci
abbiamo già visti con lascia in mano ha
cercato di zoppicare fuori dal bunker ma
per fortuna della troppo lenta e siamo
riusciti a spiegare non sia intenzioni
con la lama della cia riscaldata abbiamo
difettato la ferita jolo tagliarlo il
braccio o errato al caso sistema
immunitario contrastare il peggioramento
in tutto ciò abbiamo dovuto sacrificare
lascia ma ora lei sta meglio se non mi
lascio la porta di tenere lo stesso
prova devono mangiare tutti qualcosa
ragazzi non ho più niente deve tornare
il padre adesso ieri durante un gioco di
mimì abbiamo scoperto di mary jane non
sa dire disagi
mary jane non sa dire this arcivescovo
ma porca [ __ ] this arcivescovo ma non
lo so dire neanch'io this arcivescovo
tantino polizzari ed ora si è rimasta
molto male insiste che volete l'america
elezioni a casa non lo so dire neanche
io però va bene noi tornato il padre
dammi dei delle provviste non mi serve
l'acqua dai ragazzi
no ragazzi è stato fuori due anni e ha
portato solo due bottiglie d'acqua solo
due ma cosa me ne faccio non raga sono
morto ho perso
vedete non ho mai mangiato non lo so non
ho provviste siete morti portico demonio
manda dolores ragazzi siamo morti non
niente ogni tanto cicoli di corse felice
di suonare qualcosa di creare suoni
armoniosi da condividere con il mondo
raga siamo morti come faccio a spiegarlo
di cantare e suonare ed essere circolati
da tenere arrivare i mutanti che ci
ascoltano come biancaneve post
apocalittica ci proviamo certo anzi
frozen le righe morti o è una vita che
non mangiano sono morti però ci sono
delle cose qua dopo aver suonato un paio
di minuti un gruppetto di scarafaggi
mutanti è saltato fuori dalle crepe e ha
iniziato a muoversi a ritmo di musica
girava su se stessi agitavano le
antennine sarebbe stato adorabile se non
fossero disgustosi cosa dobbiamo farci
di loro mangiateli no ragazzi mangiateli
non so cosa darvi ve lo giuro
devo curarne due non ho medikit devo
dare a mangiare a tutti e non o cibo
esce la mamma ma io non so veramente
cosa altro fare ne esce solo per per
vederla ritornare immagino timi è morto
è scappato perché aveva fame come
fossero i sopravvissuti senza cibo
la situazione si aggrava sempre più i
nostri occhi riflettono fame
disperazione
sappiamo che un insegnante locale ci ha
salvato di bambini e conosciamo anche le
provviste presenti nel rifugio
scolastico come parte della comunità
abbiamo contribuito a raccogliere per le
emergenze le emergenze quinto riccamente
sarebbero anche nostre no subito rubati
cibo ai bambini in chi se ne frega
morite il lato oscuro
abbiamo preso del cibo è tornato pure
mary jane tutto tutto tutto tutto
tuttavia guarda guarda la borraccia giga
tutto
mamma mia proprio loro che sopravvivono
così rubando dai bambini la mappa ra qua
che abbiamo trovato la mappa non avevamo
idea che avesse installato un sistema di
allarme intorno alla porta del rifugio
appena abbiamo provato ad aprirla siamo
stati attaccati con mattoncini e
bacchette da lavagna credevamo ci
passerà mai
gli insegnanti hanno lasciato ai bambini
fuori per fare spazio per se stessi
siamo sconcertati gli insegnati crudeli
e stato bello vedere il dolore quindi
loro niente non ho trovato nulla hanno
rubato la supermercato più 4 di zuppa
più 6 di acqua io voglio piangere di
gioia incredibile ci serve
guarda più di allora dite vi sono nella
migliore spedizione del mondo più 4
zuppa più se di acqua più fucile più
torcia più mappa più insetticida abbiamo
perso però la valigia però vabbè dai
mamma mia che culo da bere e da mangiare
a tutti
mammamia da bere sono posso sfamare tre
rifugi l'ultima spedizione ha scovato un
veicolo parcheggiato in fondata da un
aspetto singolare ma nessuno è mai
riuscito avere allora vicino siamo
abbastanza certi che non si tratti di
una trappola dei banditi
dovremo dare un'occhiata veit ed una
scoperta sensazionale che un carro
armato i bordi si sbriciola gli manca
qualche ruota ma i sedili sono
discretamente comodi non sarebbe
magnifico metterlo in moto e lasciare in
questo inferno e ho capito come facciamo
ma dai poi fuggire col carro armato ma
che fino adesso non sembra essere
migliorata la tua ha portato il kit
medico ragazzi non ce l'ho mi spiace il
nostro kit medico non serve a nulla dato
che non siamo in grado di procurarsi i
farmaci prendiamo in mano la situazione
per esempio perché non usare questi no
qui insetticida per creare farmaci
salvavita ragazzi se ci riuscite io vi
amo danno grado non ci credo
va bene va bene va bene va bene va bene
subito diamo a tutti del 91
al padre dai che sopravvive louis
teoricamente ragazzi il padre è l'unico
vivo praticamente di tutto questo mary
jane è stata soprattutto sgattaiolare
via nel cuore della notte dolore si è
infuriata quando ha scoperto che aveva
un appuntamento con un giovane bandito
sembra che abbia incontrato durante una
spedizione mary jane chiesto di poterlo
fare una biglietto di scuse per non
essersi presentata che sia una buona
idea
sì tanto sta morendo peggio di così
qualche provvista extra ci farebbe
comodo durante l'ultima spingerebbe
notato un carro armato danneggiato e lo
so colore prima è mandare i jane e.coli
prima manda che è successo seguito una
bomba di sparato col carro armato porco
demonio che è successo noi ci
aspettavamo di certo un'esplosione
enorme abbiamo sentiti frammenti
ricadere ma come e colpire la nostra già
misera di moral mano il mezz'ora di
certo disseminato di trappole esplosive
ma dai è morta mary jane perché è
saltata su una mina va dai le ferite di
dolores sono state ignorate allungo
vedono nel piatto nato ne vede a posto
tende sta da dio che non so cosa dire no
finito perché questo manova come avevo
ancora cibo questi giorni senza acqua
solo film ma come senza ma come è morto
ma come mai ce l'avevo l'acqua a perché
non gliel'ho data subito madama erano
passati due no ragazzi ma non ci credo
erano passati due giorni dall'ultima 3d
rodata pensavo di durare la metà del
tempo ma neanche perché ero messo da
cani invece più di 50 giorni ma avrei
voluto veramente vedere come sarebbe
andata col carro armato perché il carro
armato mi interessava tantissimo lo
fuggire col carro armato bellissima idea
cosa sento ragazzi se video più giù
lasciato un bel commento mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciate la
campanellina bisogna manette aggiornati
se non riescono come sempre ci vediamo
al prossimo vinto dai ragazzi
[Musica]